[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to opera how do we
talk about whatever we want and we have
our beautiful Giovanni thank you yeah I
miss you guys dude in a wild what's the
last last time that you came with Jake a
news no I did I think before my birthday
dude you this [ __ ] just blow into a
[ __ ] tube yeah air what in there yeah
he blew it like he blew it four times he
can make a sound what the best part is
that he's like yeah [ __ ] I'll try to get
my Ray Charles on I just remember this
is the kind that takes a little time to
learn oh you gonna melt it right yeah
you got a flute oh well maybe because
it's on your lip maybe put it underneath
your lip do you think do you think that
your musician father is part of you
right now I think he's uh wherever he's
that he's looking at me and saying
that's my son yeah yeah he got it yeah I
didn't make it very far apparent no that
was no that's that's pride I can hear it
from miles and miles away oh it hasn't
sleeve I didn't know that are you
putting it back this is luxurious isn't
the sleeve just soak up all the saliva I
hope that one's the upgraded one so when
I got to do the baby ones and then that
one will be like the top top level top
shelf Steve what is it like sitting next
to Joe it's imagine I get to be right
here you know nobody gets to see this
angle I get this I can't I just see this
I get the profile baby you if you could
only imagine what it's like oh don't
turn your head if he turns your body Joe
there you go it's okay that's part of it
I don't know what's gonna happen
yeah what about all this [ __ ] on the
desk yeah me I'm used to I'm kinda I
gotta kind of a yes Nikki it's not that
far from what I do well you guys are
very similar
cuz witness when I'm on the table I look
I look over at Nikki and I'm like damn
Nikki you're [ __ ] mess some cat
stickers she does the same [ __ ] I'm like
it starts off with like one piece of
napkin and then it just starts trailing
all the way up and I'm like damn
thank you you both sit there I'm
constantly checking the viewfinder and
make sure like none of that messes in
frame so you guys don't even know what
the hell it creeps up it goes from here
to like here and in here and in after
lunch we already have junk all the way
up to here we have we have we have some
money there's a lot of stuff a shitty
knots when I get in the car - Nikki now
has cuz she's been on this diet so she
now brings her lunch everywhere she
always has some kind of glass container
Tupperware thing and it's always rolling
around in the car eating some coffee
mugs so you're like cling-clang
cling-clang anytime i turn anywhere
that's we with bottles I just have
bottles of like half drunk water and
it's just rolling all over beer bottles
that'd be great
Oh that'll be fine [ __ ] beer bottles
on it if I drank I'd probably be being
alcohol there yeah anyways what we were
you just been here for you haven't been
here in a year that's 29 that's crazy
crazy that is crazy you have a new
outlook on life not a 230 I want to kill
myself can I just say that I think that
you've been 30 for a while yeah we can I
only say that because because you're you
don't want to go off my lights your
words no no no no cuz I'm this way I'm
this way I have faith in you I think she
doesn't want to go out that much right
she's like like she likes to chill a lot
when the idea of like going to somewhere
and like you look it up and you're like
oh do I wouldn't wanna go out tonight or
do I want to chill at home that's at the
time when geo voicemail see that's the
30 old mindset well I just I just had
your back you know cuz you're such a
hater cuz you're a chick and chicks are
hitters
no you thought that I was gonna be like
oh cuz you're 30 cuz you got a lines on
your face or some [ __ ] singing in that
direction
we called it yeah that's how you've made
your fun I had faith in you trolling
yeah steve is a vulnerable gentlemen
thank you both his wife he was [ __ ]
colorblind for a fool never does for the
[ __ ] yes for the bit
I changed I will do things for the bit
not to change man contradicting yourself
oh no I'm a changed man oh [ __ ] it threw
me under the bus huh yes yeah that's
[ __ ] up I did how did she thrown on
the bus uh because she was saying Oh cuz
you know he wasn't giving are you even
here right now yeah you know I'm just
examining the fact that girls hand get
along even with themselves that's
exactly right
Wow good for you okay are you proud of
yourself super I accomplished something
today and that was it and no more oh
yeah but me like it's it's been like
well yeah you've been thirty since you
were 21 yeah I have a cat
exactly I turned yeah I've been thirty
for like five years now yeah you're like
the most like unpardonable this things
and you're just like I [ __ ] want to
go home yeah it's true dude something
goes what's going on with the drama at
my party what Rama your party my
birthday party we know all of it the
magician it's just Elton I'm dope is
that Steve how come you know no I don't
know wait when Elton is just have some
name I wish I had just Gina cuz it's not
that common
yeah can I just apologize to Elton real
quick Elton I'm very sorry that you're
very sensitive did I like your name I
love you Elton no I was just [ __ ] on
it you know but magic is kind of wack
unless you're Penn & Teller Maisie he
was really good it's all like his heart
break through his Isaac you came up to
him and you're like what was it how does
the thing you told him you're like
excuse me I'm sorry I have to interrupt
but your magic so unless you I didn't
say that
great that's not true I was [ __ ] with
him it's um I know I just said that Matt
I know I was just making fun of him how
magic is done he's all unless he pulls
up shits on a rabbit it's not magic
something that was directed to him and I
remember seeing like his whole life like
shatter your dream killer no listen it's
my that's my [ __ ] Matt sets defense
mechanism no because I could see if
you'd it's not responsible I need to
though yeah I think it's his fault
though so magic is dope right it's it's
like you create this optical illusion in
front of people
so you're tricking people but if you
don't have confidence in what you're
doing Steve's gonna sense it so he's not
even really attacking the magic he's
just like Oh what are you doing like
these weird things at a party for and
then if he's just slowly getting crushed
isn't it his own confidence issues
Steve's preparing him for Vegas you need
to see a psychologist or some shop that
brought alcoholic Bobo to the party I
will probably not be going there I got a
good one I got a good one now I gotta
get both no no I'm just saying because
he's because I made him cry this chicks
are amazing he made you sign a card
right and he transferred that signature
to another card same car but you need
like transferred it in between the decks
ins yeah that's crazy and like made it
up I should threw me off okay wait I
thought I'd tilt it and I did it so he's
so dope I doesn't have confidence in
himself that's what I'm saying so okay
so this is entirely what my vet was his
magic was really good yeah and so I was
like nah dude this isn't that good and
then I did a shitty magic I was really
bad for everybody right exactly but it's
purposely very bad he's a really good
magician with low confidence I did I'm
like whoa dude and then yeah I
apparently he crumbled I didn't notice
that he crumbled no I mean we yeah I
know so then we were all just like it's
okay don't worry he's just being a troll
like it's okay cuz I thought his magic
was good that's why I thought it was a
funny bit yeah
so he doesn't believe in himself it's
like he's really good but he's just
still kind of like wondering if people
exist that's like me going to David
Copperfield and being like hey man it's
not that good watch this [ __ ] I do some
shitty thing and then he starts crying
right now I don't have the childhood
trauma that makes us into a strong
people that we are today that he
shouldn't do magic he's building gifts
like I said you're getting him ready for
Vegas to do that [ __ ] though I wasn't
even trying to make him actually sad
that's what suppose my mind but we love
you Oh goddammit so what's the drama so
dude okay so did you guys notice well
well I got the coffee second did you
guys notice that at the party the the
caterer the waiters and the bartenders
disappeared yeah and they weren't there
by the end of night when your friends
made me a drink
yeah that turn on finish we ended up
making our own drinks me and Tim and
everybody mad I didn't even know there
was bartenders yeah because they were
gone like torn they're selling to two
and a half hours to three hours left at
the party and then my planner came over
she's like dude where's our food team
like they all just left I was like oh
[ __ ] they did just leave and then so we
started blowing up the dudes phone I
think was Chris you'll [ __ ] and I was
like yo where'd you go and he would not
respond to me sorry I'm getting a
[ __ ] in a car no he's probably
jacking the Street Fighter machine dude
oh oh you got that one yeah but I
noticed a bunch of machines getting
carted out and I was like oh oh I told
him they can have it even I think the
caterers were taking about [ __ ] so and
then my plan I was texting him and then
like he finally responded and he gave us
like three reasons one of which he was
like well the neighbors came over and
they told my my team that if we don't
leave and they'll call the cops and I
was like why specifically your team like
do these guys hate [ __ ] food or
something and then he goes well some
some drunk I shoved my brother I'm like
I don't even know your [ __ ] brother
was here and then he says okay well my
brother also got into a car accident I'm
like dude what the [ __ ] you should lead
with that next time so he got he got
pushed and then he left and then he got
in a car accident
yeah I don't know maybe he's just
pulling things out of his ass and why
does it take the whole entire [ __ ]
team to go
yeah and then you said well because
somebody told the team that if they
don't leave then they'll call the cops
and I'm just like why who is this
somebody I don't know he's up the
neighbors
so like I'm like why didn't you come and
tell me the person that's paying you to
be here or my planner so we know what
the [ __ ] going on and why are you
dodging my calls and my text messages
cuz he's a [ __ ] yeah and then so he
told my planner he's like oh I'm sorry
like all these things happen can you
save my glassware for me and just toss
everything else
no the contract was you cook you serve
you clean and you cut the cake right and
so the latter half of that wasn't done
so we finally like she takes the
glassware and he's still ignoring my
text messages to a point where I told
him like dude you need to respond to me
now or this shit's gonna get ugly so you
tell him that you're gonna get the
magician and making sure disappear
that's right no you tell me you get the
magician to cry on him so he texts me
like two weeks later and he's like hey
after I pick up the glasses from Lilly
the planner that I'll pay you I'm like
okay cool it's been like two weeks he
hasn't paid me yeah so it's been about
like a month now why do we what does he
have to pay you so I hit him up in like
you know this was not cool like I'm not
gonna ask you for a full refund
because you did part of your work okay I
want like a partial refund yeah and then
he's like okay I'll refund you six
hundred originally I said five hundred
like I don't have a [ __ ] like just
refund me but he's the one that says six
hundred yeah so I've been moat charged
him nothing I've been texting him
nothing and then a week ago he's like
all right I saw him on Instagram live so
I respond I was like so you can [ __ ]
go on Instagram lie but you can't
respond to my text messages and then he
he like text me like three days later
saying oh sorry I was working that event
to get a check to pay you like broken
this [ __ ] but I told it okay you have
till Tuesday so it is what day is it
Thursday today
don't [ __ ] with Gina she's gonna put you
on blast Ashley you don't know her track
record I am always so baffled like why
do people [ __ ] with you you know or they
should know what you do that's I'm
saying because he follows all you guys
watching I think those idiots don't
expect that they're going to fail that's
what that's what they do right and then
they fail and then they go holy [ __ ] how
do I get out of this
exactly and in there an 88 so they don't
know how to get out of that mess no
making it worse
do not leave early or give me a good
reason
Gina reason of my brothers in a car
accident I need to leave now
you're [ __ ] an understanding person
you let them go but why does this whole
or like TT know my little brother just
got shoved so I need to go little
brother at the party hosting the show in
the right shoulder you understand but
what why does understanding after all
that she's just like just give me 500
bucks and we'll end this yeah still
won't even do that but why does the
bartender's in them have to go that's
what I'm saying so I messaged a
bartender I was like you know what's
going on he goes well he told me that
the neighbors came over in threatened
him so we all had to leave
what neighbors apartment on the side is
under construction
yeah yeah so it's like the thing is all
I asked for was for him to tell me what
happened and then I would have been like
okay cool just go or at least just
refund me least that's all I just need a
communication that sounds so weird so I
told him okay you have till Tuesday
Tuesday passes I remind him like yo you
need to pay me today nothing this is why
the Mafia exists you need to like send
people that'll beat his ass and make him
a [ __ ] adult I mean I know we know
the same people but at the same time I'm
saying this is this is why they exist
because this has to happen update as
recently yesterday this [ __ ]
text me at 10 o'clock at night with a
picture of a prescription pad with the
prescription written on it and a picture
of his grandpa on a wheelchair Hoss oh
he's one of those [ __ ] worst of the
worst [ __ ] in the world he's like is
it okay at the $500 goes to my sick
rapper or no do you want your 500
jitters my grandpa died blocked you on
Instagram and yes I was yeah so he sends
that photo and then he goes oh I had to
pay for my grandfather's prescription so
I'm trying to and so I hit up my doctor
friends like what are these meds they're
like that's this this and this and it's
like 20 bucks that stomach acid medicine
or hemorrhoids talents for diarrhea oh
my god what the [ __ ] is happening how do
you run into this kind of trouble what
before do you attract these people
that's how I never throw big birthday
parties I wanted it to be like he knows
who we are he like he has to know how I
do my okay so how did this all go down
because you gotta be somewhat kind of
organized and talented to have a
catering company I don't know if you
guys check but he hit me up on my dams
two before her party saying like hey if
you're ever new catering services now
it's over bro yeah why don't you damn in
him and go once you pay [ __ ] Gina
back I would love that
pretty good though the photos really
good it was really good I was gonna hire
these guys to do my magician's roast you
can hire the actual magician that you're
roasting right Tim throws I just don't
think it's gonna happen I'm looking for
another vendor I have to say though they
made some good food they make good food
I know I hate them now but the Tim I
don't don't [ __ ] rip you off though so
at what cost
yeah when they [ __ ] over to Tim we
have to ask Tim reason why I hired him
was because Tim gave him let's [ __ ]
tip times kitty Tim thought they were
cool well you could [ __ ] Tim ten ways
and he'll still call you cool so I
wouldn't be okay with yeah that's my
four hours early but brother got shot so
that's it's called me Tim is one of
those guys that it's like you could do
everything wrong and as long as you know
yeah he is Zen as hell yeah I've never
seen them even yelling anybody yeah I
know someone that owes him a lot of
money and I'm like mind blown that Tim
buzzes a [ __ ] about it Tim's probably
making payments to them every month yeah
here's a nice [ __ ] yeah so
[ __ ] cool I'm like the opposite if he
sent me a sick grandpa I'd be like I
hope he died some so you could start
paying me you [ __ ] yeah like so
wheelchair yeah what the [ __ ] you owe me
money I don't tell me worries that's
like a unplug it's [ __ ] machines and
[ __ ] yeah that's why we don't
friends like that you're gonna have a
for-profit business plug of machines
doesn't make you money so I detected it
back and then I was like dude like I if
that's really what's happening I'm sorry
if it has nothing to do with me like
this is business and also you signed a
contract like he breached his own
contract that has his address on it
which is [ __ ] stupid the contract can
even have my address it wasn't like you
know stupid but his address is on there
and then it's just like oh god like this
is I think he owes you 1,200 now right
like at this point just pay me back the
whole thing is the kind of stuff this is
psychological damages because this makes
you wanna stay in your house now yeah
this got me out of the house cuz now I'm
like no because you got a super most
psychological damages psychological I
can't trust people anymore
thank you so I texted him back I was
like dude what the [ __ ] and it's just
like you look like if you can't handle
this like an adult and I'll do it my way
and then so I look at this Instagram I
noticed that he blocked me
he's been blocking me cuz he's hiding
for me like if you're really trying to
pay me back why would you block me but
still follow like everyone else like he
was trying really hard trying to get
like everyone to work with him no I like
I can't see his account from my
Instagram I can't search it up so I had
my friend tag him in a food post so I
can click on the name and then he tried
to add my friend like oh are you looking
for a caterer I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you got played anyhow so after JK news
today I'm actually heading straight to
the courthouse to get some small claims
court papers whatever should done don't
[ __ ] with Gina yeah and then I want to
bless them I want to blast on my
Instagram to at Iron Chef new when you
little [ __ ] I think she messaged me too
for catering services yeah thirsty
[ __ ] you know what that's why I never
want to do business with people that hit
me up out of nowhere ever ever ever ever
ever think about him before I hired him
this [ __ ] won't stop texting
dude like well cuz he wanted the bagina
wanted no he wanted the job so bad he
could have wanted the pagina I think Oh
so like I told him like I would tell him
hey uh I'm deciding between a couple of
caterers I'll let you know and he would
like text me like six more times within
like the next two hours because your
apologies only [ __ ] client and you
went for that as be a that's too
annoying for me okay maybe he's
enthusiastic cuz like I wouldn't I would
be like okay I'll let you know and I
know send me pictures of him cooking I'm
like himself yeah here's me nothing at
I'm like something yeah he's only
wearing an apron this is me cookie dick
you were buying a house and we go to
this realtor guy and he might as well
been wearing up or like a Canadian
tuxedo like [ __ ] jeans and and then
the cat he comes up to us afterward and
he's like look at all you we obviously
have to put your number down when you
walk through houses and [ __ ] and so then
he texts us afterward with a picture of
him standing the middle of the living
room
that is the follow-up from hell do you
know what he's really nice I don't know
you only texted me one picture and then
like if I if I continued not text me
because I'm trying to find like I have a
life he'll be like oh by the way um I
can get you a 5 log you pay for all by
the way I'm putting gold flakes in your
food and just like oh we gonna have this
like you know work all the flakes and if
there were gold flakes because I'm an
extra [ __ ] and I liked it yeah
but then like all of a sudden air and
then when it came to payment he would
charge me immediately and I would pay
immediately cuz he has no [ __ ] money
that's why he's using your money to
actually get the materials I would pay
immediately cuz I'm a grown-ass [ __ ]
adult but takes care of my [ __ ] but then
now that he owes me money he can't be
[ __ ] to text me and he can't be [ __ ] to
send me my venmo so once again that's
iron chef know it on Instagram yeah iron
show work with you in don't work with
him I was I was waiting for tip to sue
JK because on account of that she looks
tired and that affects her livelihood
yes something yes the chef small
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]